[Music]
the difference in
the new personalised medicine trials is
that for the
first time we won't actually be
having the result of the trial applying
to a large population
it'll only apply to a relatively small
subgroup so
those entered into the trial have less
of a chance of benefiting unless we
target the treatment appropriately but
the real issue is as we divide
a population up into increasingly small
subsets we run the risk of having
underpowered
trials if we try and do things the way
we've done them with big randomised
studies
to sort out the efficacy and toxicity
of new treatments so what we're going to
have to do is a whole new paradigm
probably
n of one studies proof of principle
studies if you will
a small study to look at efficacy and
toxicity
and then the interrogation of large
digital databases to fine-tune
results that we would have otherwise
done in separate randomized trials and
if we don't do that
we run the risk of doing trials that
we'll never get the answers that
we want from them
genetic counselling is interesting
because
we're not only dealing with the person
involved in the counseling the
information
and the implications of that information
apply to their relatives
as well and so it's far broader
and so issues that are conventional
about privacy of the individual simply
may not be able to be applied here the
other issue with genetic counselling is
that we're giving
patients information about probabilities
of future events
and that will introduce uncertainty and
possibly a distressing uncertainty
that they need the information to be
able to make informed decisions
about their future but it's quite
different from
other medicine which is working towards
a
certain outcome we're actually
introducing what could be quite a
distressing uncertainty
[Music]
big data is all about hyper
connectability of data bringing in data
sets from many different places and
joining them together
and it's actually about data linkage and
for linking data you need it to be
identified while you link it and then
de-identified when it's analyzed and you
report
the results and the problem is always
whether there can be either
re-identification or whether there can
be a problem in the
linkage set of keeping the data
identified so is the
patient's privacy going to be respected
but then we have the problem as
the data set fans out it's not clear
always whether it will be used by others
for the purpose for which the person who
donated their data intended and it's
very difficult
to know whether they can give broad
enough consent to be able to
keep on interrogating the the big
database
as time goes on
tissue banks are problematic ethically
because they involve
taking some tissue and linking that
with clinical data sets so you need
identification of the data to allow the
linkage
and then when you're reporting on the
vast
biobank it should be de-identified so
a patient's information can't be linked
to them
and people worry about the privacy of
that
process so that issue has to be resolved
but the bigger issue is probably that
over time we're going to need to
use that tissue perhaps for
investigations that weren't
initially envisaged as technology and
information
change can a patient give sufficiently
broad consent to allow that to happen
what happens if the original donor is a
child or they have to re-consent
what happens if you can't recontact a
patient are you allowed to still
use that tissue sample and its
information
and the custodian of a data bank if in
fact you can identify the custodian and
that may also have implications for
commercialization
if they discover something that would be
important to the well-being of a single
individual who donated to that data bank
do they have a responsibility to report
back
and i think all of these things need to
be sorted
out in a governance process prior to
setting up the data bank
[Music]
genomic policy really has to be
about privacy genomic data is
is so powerful that re-identifying
an individual could be quite problematic
for them so
the protection of their individual data
in a large database is important but i
guess the the other
issue that would worry people is the
possibility
that their genomic data could be used to
discriminate against them
for example in being able to be insured
medical insurance travel insurance or
even their employment prospects in
particular high-risk
employment chances that they may have
and we don't want to see that the sort
of discrimination
certainly if we've got some of the
population uh having
genomic tests and others without and
there'd be a difference between those
two so we need to
actually protect people against the
their data being misused in that way
[Music]